my name is Benji Shan I'm working with
the App Inventor team and the idea of
app inventors we can well we're
democratizing the creation of mobile
apps so a new user with no previous
experience and no previous programming
experience can make an app in about five
to ten minutes and that's possible
through our visual block space language
so it looks something like this so
instead of the traditional language
where you're just typing just text
you're Connecting Blocks almost like a
puzzle or Legos so my project is really
understanding the usage of how people
use these blocks so I've created a
logging system to log the step-by-step
process a user would follow in app
creation so
you with these logs you you can recreate
the entire process and really identify
maybe really understand what the user
was thinking throughout the entire
development process
so the first things I'm addressing are
looking at errors in in App Inventor so
a lot of our assumptions are that people
use text languages similar to blocked
languages but we're not sure if that's
true so first things I'm looking at are
errors so there's two of them the first
one is called a bump away error so the
idea is that when blocks that should
never connect are tempted to be
connected people they will be bumped
away so we want to try to understand
what blocks our most most often bumped
away so which ones are most confusing
and what was the block they're actually
looking for what was how do they debug
and find the correct block another one
is runtime errors so
with app and then you can actually pair
App Inventor with a mobile device so as
you're developing your app you can see
the app it apps change in real time so
we can also catch runtime errors or
errors that happen as the as the code is
being run
so right now I'm in uh early in my
research so I'm actually doing any
experiments at Prospect Hills Academy
where I'm helping teach a class on Apple
better to 10th grade students and those
10th grades we're collecting data from
those 10th grade students